I don't know I question what I should
have died in you know I question a lot
it safe to say that by now we've all
seen hanabi's return to Peter season of
The Bachelor
do you regret sending me home at all
okay yeah Peter I question it all the
time I genuinely thought when I decided
yeah I would be The Bachelor
that I was in a spot where I could do
that and I was ready and I had moved on
this real emotions kind of come up and
it was all real it was all there's a
real relationship we had well now hannah
is also reacting to her appearance and
let me tell you her responses are
hilarious first writing that the day
marked her worst birthday ever then
quote spoiler alerts this is going to be
very freaking awkward we then got a
windmill joke because well obviously
quote I just want to go hide under the
windmill right now because of you two
nobody will ever look at a windmill the
same I did say there was something that
Peter and I did twice it was actually
four times
Wow that was all funny Hannah then got a
little more serious writing quote so
that was not a blast at all it was truly
the hardest day a day I was not looking
forward to reliving but thank you to
those of you who have been so sweet and
supportive tonight we also know that at
the time her appearance was taped she
was also competing on Dancing with the
Stars which she ended up winning so it's
fitting that she gave a shout-out to her
partner Alan Burstyn quote also shout
out to Alan for teaching me a rumba
after this that we survived that week
was truly a victory now it's unclear how
much more of Hannah we're gonna see on
Peter season
I don't know what I'm doing this is so
insane what would you say if I asked you
to come
would be part of the hot house
maybe like oh my gosh but she did give
us this hint last month we know you were
filming dancing but then we also saw you
on Peters preview for the season of The
Bachelor how much are we actually gonna
see of you I don't know I mean I feel
like we put two and two together like I
worked my ass off to win that beer ball
so I don't know I was in the studio 8
hours a day so I don't know let's we
want to do the math on that one math and
watch in January mm-hmm Peter himself
also had a lot to say about Hannah's
return so do we get an ending for you
too because if we're doing the math on
how much she was filming Dancing with
the Stars there's no way she was on your
whole season of The Bachelor everyone
thinks that but I mean she's not filming
the entire week okay and you know maybe
the locations weren't so far from LA so
I don't know so are you and Hannah
together right now
I can say I am very happy without
everything I did and I'm excited that
there's a reason and no one you're gonna
find out Jenny and I'm excited about
that
oh and host Chris Harrison also weighed
in giving us this look in all
seriousness her and Peter they just they
just have this thing that intangible
kind of chemistry and it's one of those
things that no matter how much you think
you're over somebody when you see each
other it's a thing let them deal with
that on the show but it's a thing and
there is some serious chemistry between
the two that's just undeniable and
that's why we wanted to have her back on
the show
all right guys a lot to unpack here but
if the premiere was any indication this
season of The Bachelor is going to be
freaking amazing for all the latest on
Peter and Hannah
stick with all things et until next time
I'm Katie crafts and five for now
[Music]